Genghis khan wasn't unusual.
Conqueror,
yes,
he subdued vast lands from a top a horse,
but he didn't brag loudly across the ages.
He kept secrets,
a secret history,
a secret burial,
no images from his life.
Conquered peoples weren't even allowed to learn his language with all this
secrecy,
could we ever know what is language sounded like
my first encounter with Mongolian.
Imagine me working at a coffee shop for years.
I spent my morning steaming customized Espresso elixirs for customers to carry
out with style,
but after my shift,
I'd relax by heading three blocks to the library and picking grammars off the
stacks.
This day I noticed a new book.
I opened it and met a language that built words mechanically that had val
harmony,
long vowels and an l.
It warned me it would be tricky to pronounce fun until one example broke my
flow.
Something something,
something Ching is con.
Suddenly this wasn't just grammar.
It felt like history Mongolian the Mongols was this the remnant voice of the
Great Khan himself.
I didn't realize it at the time,
but this curiosity would lead me down in epic road.
Books,
maps a pig roughy late into the night following nomadic hoof prints to chase a
language and if you want in on that journey,
we travel to Mongolia today,
fly into lawn Baltar's,
the red hero city,
and you'll see one name at the airport on bottles.
Oh,
hotel a bank and the character atop top,
the world's largest mat on horse statues,
southeast of town.
Not Ganga is calm,
but chicken is hard.
Yes,
in Cyrillic,
no,
this isn't Russian.
It's Mongolian.
Just like in that grammar endings with vowel harmony post positions,
not prepositions.
Long vowels like hung and L's and L's have
crossed the border into China and you're an Inner Mongolia.
As you look around at shops and signs,
it can be hard to imagine that a roving shrine to Gaviscon once toward this
region for the devout after his death,
but focus above the Chinese and you'll spot some Mongolian in an older alphabet
with toothy consonant vowel letters connected along a cursive spine.
It's unique in the way it's written from top to bottom in a rose from left to
right for beginners.
It's a challenging script.
I mean this thing kind of breaks webpages,
but to ease the pain.
Children here learn it as syllables.
When they recite words with these syllables,
something strange happens.
Extra unspoken syllables emerge.
The word he can delay.
The Blue City of Inner Mongolia is Cole who quota and the four syllables of who
John Balter are written with six.
Where do these extra syllables come from?
From back in time?
1204 before he is con the up and coming too.
Muchin conquers a tribe to the south,
the Nema among his new subjects as a scholar Patona who writes in the weaker
script,
which is people inherited ultimately from Aramaic.
There's a whole backstory,
but if it reminds you of rotated Arabic,
there is a reason to move,
maybe illiterate,
but he immediately recognizes the use for is dawning empire and so trusted
Mongol Nobles.
Learn to write later that same century.
A great stone goes up with an inscription telling us that is skilled archery's
sooner shot a target from 335 volts away more than half a kilometer.
The first words in the texts reveal who was there to witness it.
Genius harm and his mangled dignitaries.
This is pre classical written Mongol.
It often resembles modern Mongolian like kid is still a good,
but it preserves sounds that have since changed like [inaudible] has since
harmonize to older.
Those long vowels were actually two vowels split by Kahan instead of Han,
which by the way is why Khan also gets spelled with two Oz and I'd heard between
this official written language takes us back to the right time,
but another line of evidence suggested might be suspiciously archaic,
how dignitaries rope,
but not how the cottons spoke.
A crucial piece of the Mongolian story was nearly forgotten.
A history book disguised as a language instruction text was rediscovered by
Russian Orthodox Monk Palladium in China in the mid 18 hundreds this book was
written entirely in Han Chinese characters,
but despite appearances,
it doesn't make sense if it's read in Chinese.
Listen to the very first words gene geese car hon,
we meet again.
What emerges is a long name filled text telling the inside story of the man
himself.
His origins from Tingey,
his under his blood brother is conquest with his general struggle for
succession.
Even a cameo by that same long shot.
Archer Oh and time and again you'll read how in is hand made a decree.
He made a decree saying dot,
dot.
Dot.
It all struck scholars and nomads alike as authentic,
perhaps composed upon his very death.
When Knoebel's gathered together to remember his story,
their story,
and wrote down what came to be known as new Cha Cha,
the secret history.
It's from the right time,
but something felt off.
It had already changed to Udl.
They were already dropping their middle hoods and yet they kept around and
initial hook who Joe would in all of this secret history looked different,
mostly younger,
maybe written Mongol was too old to be the language of the [inaudible].
Maybe this was his middle Mongol.
So why not just roll back today's pronunciation and undo sound changes to revert
to our best middle Mongol accent is the question you ask yourself as we travel
the open road through the old dose in Inner Mongolia to this site of the muzzle,
Liam of Chinks,
hon or those became our horde,
but it means palaces.
His tomb remains a mystery.
Yet after his death tent palaces wandered.
This land is a shrine to what one scholar terms Ganga said theology and
terrorism of people called the dotcom vowed to guard it forever and they're
Mongolian is different.
They're not alone.
There are languages in Russia than inherit over 90% of their words from Middle
Mongol.
Well,
one in China keeps less than half as I promised.
It's a lot of wandering,
but the point is there's not one Mongolian.
It's among Golick family.
Even my grammar naively titled Mongolian was teaching just one variety.
HEISC linguists sifted through Mongolia cognates to piece together a common
ancestor.
Prodo Mongolia had a low,
not it had no F's.
The hug had a or not and a final hadn't merged with [inaudible] so they were
saying Kahan has were dropping,
but lingered at the start of words was wrong,
was who lon sometimes evidenced conflicts was their garb.
A dip in or Dicken reveals quirks,
Mongols used echo nouns for and things like that.
Muddy,
muddy for horses and Moross and look so much like Middle Mongol,
like another line of evidence pointing back to the exact same time.
Only 800 years ago.
It's a very young family compared to others we've met.
It's hard to reach beyond that.
So here he sits.
Before him,
we detect Turkic loans,
like is very title,
maybe dialects or even a link to this mysterious script after him,
many Mongolia descendants and between a linguistic bottleneck caused by a man
who United a people and drew a line in the Gobi sand from which emerged a
language family through old texts and modern voices.
We still hear echoes of when he made a decree,
he a decree,
but without saying the sound fun.
So add is linguistic legacy to the many accomplishments of a man who to us is
Gaviscon who in Mongolia is remembered as changes harm,
but who in his own tongue may have been chinkies Kahan
stick around and subscribing for language.